we have a wonderful mission statement
that we haven't changed in a long time
and that mission statement is the
protection and enjoyment of ocean waves
and beaches for all people the stunning
thing for me as chief executive of
surfrider foundation is how well people
understand that and from that vision
statement to some degree we don't care
what they do they can have a Brazilian
slant on it they can have a European
educational model they can do things in
Japan new things in Australia in Central
America and Santa Monica in Rhode Island
because they're all coming back to that
same mission statement and amazingly
enough almost none of my job is slapping
people into lying or telling them they
can't do something because they
understand that under the protection and
enjoyment of ocean waves and beaches
that coastal Beach area there are some
core things that we do there's beach
access there's clean water there's all
these types of things so people get it
and they get it everywhere they get it
in every language and in every culture
it's really cool that that I'm not the
cop really ever